notre collègue thomas gerbet nous
apprenait ce matin vous pouvez retrouver
son papier intégrale d'ailleurs sur
notre site de web de radio-canada que
dès 6 h et celle des privés
conventionnés avait averti québec de
l'hécatombe à venir dès mars 2020 qu on
va écouter ce qui s'est passé à la
période de questions et on y revient
avec mes invités
deux ans qu'ils disent qu'ils n'ont pas
d'équipement de protection quand est ce
que le premier ministre a su qu'ils
allaient particulièrement touchés nous
unit et quand est-ce qu'il a posé des
gestes concrets pour les protéger à
chaque matin sept jours sur sept je
demandais aux responsables du ministère
de la santé où on en était dans les
inventeurs d'équipements de protection
individuelle effectivement on est venu
proche d'en manquer money nous en reste
et pour trois semaines et mois pour deux
semaines menée pour une semaine mais
jamais on est arrivé à 0 par contre ce
qu'on a appris plus tard c'est qu'il y
avait des établissements qui avaient
plus de direction et donc qui ont pas
nouvelle ânerie pour avoir des
équipements additionnels à chaque fois
qu'il ya une nouvelle révélation bon on
apprend que le gouvernement nous cache
des choses qu'il manque de transparence
alors ce matin moi je me sens trahi je
me sens trahi parce que je me fiais sur
le premier ministre les québécois et
québécoises au site central
comment se fait-il qu'en décembre pu
dire qu'il n'avait commis aucune erreur
alors qu'il savait très bien ce que nous
on attend la celle
mes invités années que lavoie directrice
de l'association des établissements
privés conventionnés
elle représente 59 2 412 6 h celle du
québec etc vous madame lavoie qui avait
sonné l'alarmé on a la liste de vos
courriels on va les présenter au public
dans un instant dès le mois de mars si
courriel avait été déposé en preuve à
l'enquêté du coroner de l'homme kamel
est bon sans même l'avoir merci d'être
avec nous ce soir et maître patrick
martin ménard vous êtes avocat
spécialisé en droit de la santé mais
vous êtes présents quotidiennement à
cette enquête du coroner et vous
représentez donc des victimes de cette
première vague bon soir maître marty
manas au soir alors madame lavoie avant
d'aller présenter au public
les différents courriel que vous en avez
envoyé de 19 mars aux autorités quand
quelle est votre réaction à cet échange
ce matin quand vous entendez le premier
se dire on n'a jamais levé la main il
manquait directeur puis personne n'a
levé la main votre réaction
je suis vraiment pour le ch et celle du
public parce que effectivement dans ces
établissements alors il n'y avait pas de
gestionnaire un spectacle sur le terrain
par contre dans les établissements
privés conventionnés
on a un propriétaire gestionnaire qui
prévient enfin bien sûr c'est qu'ils ont
constamment sur le terrain pour réagir
et durant la première vague pour été
rejetée à l'herbe l'été présent dans
sept jours sur sept des douze heures par
jour pour être sûr que tout est sous
contrôle mais vous avez levé la main au
nom de 49,6 à celle des privés
conventionnés
50e contre 51
vous avez levé la main vous avez les
échos de ce qui se passe sur le terrain
ce qu'elle fait parce que j'étais en
communication en tous les jours avec les
différents membres de l'association qui
me rapportait ce qui se passait et qu'il
ne faisait pas beau la de leurs
inquiétudes ont ainsi qu'éviter est très
bien je reviens à vous dans un instant
votre réaction vous mettre par terre
mais là qu'est ce que ça vient ajouter
au dossier
devant la coroner kemmel et la réaction
vous avez entendu ce matin de monsieur
legault écoutez ce vient se rajouter à
toute l'information qu'on a appris
depuis le début d'une enquête du coroner
sur les nombreux signaux que le
gouvernement avait en fait par rapport à
l'hécatombe à venir en 6 h et celle
d'e.on à ma voix avait déjà fait état de
plusieurs de ses démarches lors de son
témoignage devant la devant le coroner
de voir si c'est vraiment c'est encore
une fois démontré que le gouvernement
avait beaucoup d'informations sur
le niveau de risque qui était présenté
par des sièges s'est levé sur le manque
d'équipements de protection sur le fait
aussi que l'équipement de protection
n'était pas distribué comme il a rejoint
distribués notamment dans les chercher
ciel vies privées conventionnées et donc
ça vient se rajouter on fait à toutes
les formations qu'on connaît déjà ces
sujets là donc madame lavoie nous dit
que dans le fond le premier se distingue
entre les sièges et celle des privés est
en cours de route on aura désigné des
directeurs d'établissements les privés
avaient des directeurs d'établissement
des propriétaires en fait est ce que
vous faites la même nuance quant à la
circulation de l'information maintenant
tu m'énerves aussi clair qu'il y avait
déjà des parts dans le système public en
tant que tel il y avait un problème de
circulation d'informations d'information
ne se rendaient pas toujours jusqu'où
elle est leur existence notamment sur le
terrain c'était encore pire dans les
cirques le ciel des privés alors qu'ils
avaient vraiment le canal de
communication en place
au niveau des très nombreuses directives
qui étaient envoyés jour après jour un
pas en même temps les courriels de
madame lavoie sont l occasion de
produits va prendre quelques secondes
sur les i numérique je vais date par
date madame lavoie le 19 mars un extrait
plusieurs 6h et celle des sont en
situation précaire et critique le 20
mars le sous-ministre adjoint monsieur
des biens vous répond le ministère n'a
pas d'inventaire la majorité des
établissements sont en manque deux pays
donc d'équipement et ce jour là monsieur
legault à l'assemblée nationale afin de
déclarations on l'écouté
je vous dire aussi qu'on a assez
d'équipements à court terme des masques
et respirateurs
c'est certain alors que tout le monde
dans le monde vont chercher pour
l'instant moi je veux rassurer tout le
monde court terme il n'y a pas de besoin
d'équipement
bonjour madame lavoie vous répondez vous
réécrivez le même jour pour dire que
vous comprenez pas pourquoi le premier
ministre dit cela vous rester sans
réponse le lendemain le 21 mars vous
écrivez nous sommes rendus à un niveau
de grande urgence les approvisionnements
doivent être fait aujourd'hui
et le 1er avril je crois que des actions
musclées doivent être prises car le
québec s'en va vers une hécatombe en
sièges celle dés le 1er avril on est dix
jours avant et rennes est ce que vous
comprenez pourquoi vous n'avez jamais eu
de réponse significative de gestes
significatifs à vos signaux d'alarmé
malheureusement non je ne m'explique
toujours pas pourquoi on
les informations que je transmettais au
ministère promener les exploits sur les
terrains
dans le mouvement il ya les pros du coup
ils nous ont dit que
vous m martin ménard est ce que vous
comprenez l'absence de réponse d'action
donc simon peu je pense que les
courriels sont très claires et on va
vraiment un contrat ce qu'en fait entre
la situation est rapportée et la teneur
du message que le gouvernement passait à
ce moment dans la population c'était
comme conscience la terreur dans les
premières semaines la première vague le
message c'était tout va bien on a moins
de six réalisations prévues on a moins
de code que prévu donc tout est sous
contrôle et finalement aussi rendu
compte à la mi-avril qu' il y avait un
véritable hécatombe qui dirait déjà
depuis plusieurs semaines dans le siège
cld est en fait ce qu'on apprend à
travers ce courrier leurs travers
d'autres sources d'information qui ont
été déposées à l'encontre du rhône à ce
que le gouvernement avait été informé de
ce que je peux vraiment d'actions
concrètes le qui ont été prises avant la
mi avril mais ça paraît compréhensible
notamment nord est un expert en droit de
la santé vous fréquentez beaucoup le
réseau de la santé que ça tombe sur le
bureau d'un souvenez ce sont 17 juin est
ce que c'est parce que c'est trop gros
est ce que vous sentez qu'on veut
renvoyer au ministère on renvoie la
balle on veut blâmer les présidents 2
sur 6 us qui avaient pas nécessairement
plus de moyens qu'est-ce que vous des
codes il devançait bouffer un venu
écouter ce certain que effectivement on
se renvoie la balle d'un niveau à
l'autre moi je vous irez de façon plus
large les cartons qu'on a vu dans l'est
celle de l est le résultat d'une série
de décisions qui ont été prises par ce
gouvernement là pour d'une part
considéré massivement des patients des
hôpitaux ouvert de 6h shelby et d'autre
part adressé limiter le plus possible
l'accès des patients le siège social d
aux hôpitaux pendant la première vague
on a baissé de façon très large le
niveau de soin des patients cherchés
celle d'e.on a interdit l'accès aux
aidants naturels donc toutes ces
décisions là ont eu des conséquences
extrêmement lourdes et je pense donc que
c'est aussi ça sert grandement contribué
à l'hécatombe qu'on a connu et il
faudrait que la part du gouvernement et
de la part des établissements on peut
aussi être capable de reconnaître de
notre part de responsabilité à ce niveau
là c'est pas fait encore parce que le
premier se dit on a fait ce qu'on a pu
dire qu'un formation qu'on avait
maintenant donc je serai effectivement
je pense que c'est ces discours là n'a
pas vraiment sa place dans le contexte
actuel alors qu'on cherche à comprendre
que ce qui s'est passé mais quand même
quatre mille personnes sont décédées en
cherche aussi élevé et c'est vraiment
important que on en vienne là se mettre
les yeux en face des trous y regarder
que s'est il réellement passé pour qu'on
apprenne des leçons ça pour vous madame
lavoie là dessus
a tiré je pense que le gouvernement en a
déjà tiré
avec l'arrivée de monsieur dubé au
ministère la santé hilomi ont des
nouvelles règles à leur demander à ce
que les gestionnaires présent dans tous
les chu celles des sociétés déjà une
responsabilité leur de
s'assurer que tout le monde est en place
il ya eu les
mobilités et du personnel qui a été
demandé par monsieur lumière je pense
qu'ils ont déjà fait énormément d'action
tout au cours de l'été 2020 on a eu des
formations sur la prévention et le
contrôle des infections s'est propagé à
travers de l'ensemble du réseau donc
vraiment il ya des actions qui sont
prises il y aura probablement d'autres
le sont activés et c'est bon
avez vous confiance en eux la voie que
s'il devait y avoir une autre crise que
le signal les signaux de l'âme qui sera
envoyée du terrain serait mieux entendu
mieux écouter
je pense que je pense que les gens ont
bien saisi l'importance de deux des
experts sur le père est l'importance de
de ski d'abord le coût exact il encore
pour le délivrer notre monde et vous
dans quel état de l'inquiétude est ce
que je peux dire de détresse je sais pas
là je ne sais pas dans quel état êtes
vous à ce moment là comme avec tous ces
courriels coincé entre votre terrain
voir les patients peut être mourir puis
les non-réponses de québec
écoutez quoi dans cet élan quand je
revois les courriels pour nous qu'on en
volume c'est sûr et certain que
l'émotion le lait des pièces que je lis
les par procuration la détresse de même
à relier clairement parce que m 4 nages
que je me trompe pas on a tendance à
vouloir montrer du doigt les les sièges
chez des privés conventionnés parce
qu'ils seraient des sièges-lits de
seconde zone d'une certaine manière et
lorsqu'on voit ces questions de langues
sont arrivés de ce milieu là où écouter
c'est clair que puis souvent la dent à
travers le système de santé un des
mécanismes de défense du système c'est
de tenter de blâmer parce qu'il est plus
externe au système donc le siège social
des privés ont été largement blâmé par
le gouvernement par des établissements
pour une grande partie
de l'hécatombe qu'on a connu évidemment
et si on constate là c'est que justement
donc au niveau de l'association qu'il
représente et madame lavoie eu des
signaux très clairs qui ont été envoyés
et qui n'ont pas été en temps utile à
parler aux instances du mr la santé
oms retourner rapidement la tuque
aimeriez vous entendent désormais à
l'assemblée nationale à québec lorsqu'on
demande une enquête publique qui
m'arrive à entendre de la bouche du
premier ministre autorisent la santé
face à ces révélations
il a dit beaucoup de plusieurs fois
aujourd'hui personnes à table on est 14
15 le matin la personne personne de
lever la main maintenant
écoutez je pense que c'est le premier
ministre doit donner l'heure juste je
pense que le communiste doit aussi
ordonné la tenue d'une enquête publique
c'est la seule façon qui va nous
permettre de vraiment d'aller au fond
des choses le mandat de la coroner
actionnement est plus limité une enquête
publique va vraiment nous permettre de
toucher allant à l'ensemble des enjeux
importants qui doivent être touchés pour
être certain de la crise ont cessé
d'émettre avez vous quelque chose à dire
là dessus on la voit
le voyez on va utiliser
l'important c'est de faire la lumière
sur ce qui s'est passé de manière
pouvoir éviter l'île de ré
en terminant merci beaucoup
je pense que les gens les réactions
qu'ont aujourd'hui c'est que les gens
viennent pas de la force de l'impact de
vos courriels madame lavoie et qu'il
soit maintenant publics dans le domaine
public la coroner en aurait tenu compte
de penser qu avait que vous aviez cette
clairvoyance le pour la situation quand
on pense aux grands que tu arrives et
merci beaucoup à ma voix bonne chance
pour la suite
merci m fofana
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit